au lendemain des attentats du 11
septembre c'est une amérique sous lé
choc qui déclare la guerre contre le
terrorisme
quatre mois plus tard jour pour jour la
base américaine dans la baie de
guantanamo à cuba devenait une prison
extraterritoriale mourad benchellali
ressortissants français y a passé trente
mois à 18 ans il est emmené en
afghanistan par son grand frère où il
sort à embrigader dans un camps
jihadistes ou de quelques jours à peine
dans ce camp d'entraînement je comprends
que je sais bien plus grave que ça
puisque je suis dans un camp
d'entraînement terroriste mourad
quittent le camp deux jours après les
attentats du world trade center il
s'enfuit vers le pakistan où il sera
livré aux soldats américains je
comprends qu'il y ait un lien direct
entre l'endroit où je suis et l'endroit
par lequel je suis passé à savoir ce que
l'entraînement est donc le piège se
referme et puis surtout
je comprends que ma petite histoire
vient d'entrer dans cette grande
histoire après un passage dans une
prison à kandahar où il sera torturé
mourad benchellali et transférés à
guantanamo
on retrouve incarcéré au coeur d'une
base militaire américaine à cuba
et dans lequel je vais être privé de mes
droits et dans lequel je vais je vais
être détenues pendant plusieurs mois
sans aucune explication et sans aucun
statut
780 prisonniers adultes et enfants
soupçonnés de terrorisme seront détenus
à guantanamo le site de guantanamo c'est
un
véritablement un endroit de non droit on
peut revenir omar khadr un canadien
c'étaient des enfants et qui ont subi
des années de privation de liberté
exactions assez épouvantable
39 prisonniers sont toujours détenus à
guantanamo parmi eux 13 n'ont été
accusés d'aucun crime on a voulu créer
un régime ex transmanche pour juger ou
pour détenir des des criminels
extraordinaire mais je pense qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que peu importe les
crimes et chacun a des droits humains et
qu'il faut protéger les détenus les
personnes qui ont été qui sont passés
comme moi étaient simplement des
personnes qui ont qui ont payé pour les
atrocités que d'autres avaient commise
ça a été un endroit dans lequel j'ai dû
me battre pour ne pas me radicaliser et
je trouve que c'est plutôt un comble
dans une dans un système qui était qui
prétendait vouloir lutter contre le
terrorisme et est donc de fait aussi
contre la radicalisation bloquée par le
congrès barack obama n'a pas pu tenir la
promesse faite en 2009 de fermer
guantanamo
son successeur donald trump a quant à
lui décidé de maintenir ce centre de
détention en fonction et l'actuel
locataire de la maison-blanche joe biden
se montre très prudent après le retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan et
une opinion publique favorable au
maintien de cette prison ici s
mitraillette radio canada montréal